[Musique]
la télévision a été une expérience assez
anonyme pour moissac le succès de
camelot autant il a été fulgurant est
vraiment puissant selon ceux qui me le
disait donc les gens de la chaîne et
c'est autant pour moi le lendemain de la
première diffusion qui a été un carton
j'étais javert et j'étais tout seul la
veille lors c'était un truc très bizarre
ce succès impalpable voilà il était vous
en aviez le retour mais vous pourriez
pas le constater sur le terrain n'avait
pas de public
voilà la saison 6 de camelot dont vous
avez le dvd la lln professionnel avant
première a été au cinéma dire que pour
la dernière saison de la télé je me suis
dit allez faisons ça en public
donc il n'y avait pas de diffusion télé
on a été au grand rex à paris on l'a
diffusée deux fois dans la journée avec
les salles pleines
j'étais avec eux j'ai tout regardé avec
un jour et voilà j'étais avec les gens
il ya une autre tour il ya eu les
centaines de milliers d'exemplaires
vendus c'est donc il y avait un public
jeune la table mais en plus de ça je
vais pas faire celui qui est je suis un
artisan mais je suis extrêmement fier
d'avoir je vous le dis hein tout à fait
commercialement battu les américains
avec camelot le dvd à près de 500000
exemplaires
ah non la neutralité de la série c'est
plus d'un million cinq cent mille mais
c'est passé le dernier non non c'est
tout confondu c'est un million cinq cent
mille mais je veux dire par là il ya eu
une année où on a vendu plus que 24
heures chrono lost et c'est donc que je
suis très fier de ça ça paraît un peu
pas pas forcément pour les retours
pécuniaire mais je veux dire c'est sur
ce même film a fait du bien de ce que
l'école est que les français ils aiment
un truc autant que les autres c'est une
fierté on est capable de comprendre
avant juste pour préciser ce que vous
avez fait avant camelot
donc il ya eu du théâtre si vous avez
été auteur vous avez joué vous avez
réalisé
et d'un court métrage qui s'appelait
dies irae qui est un peu le précurseur
de ces 1/4 d'heure autour de la table
ronde
voilà et puis et puis il ya eu camelot
épopée médiévale burlesque c'est un peu
la bonne définition seller pas mal j'en
ai une meilleure c'est la véritable vie
du roi arthur
oui mais ça c'est faux non ya pas de
véritable roi arthur presque oui il ya
plein de choses tout ceux qui
connaîtraient pas la série il ya le fait
que c'est une reconstitution enfin il
une qualité visiteurs vous êtes un
artisan il ya une qualité à la fois
d'image dans les costumes dans les
éclairages donc on a quelque chose qui
est vraiment de la grande grande
production
il ya des
et des guest stars comme disent les
américains c'est à dire des artistes
importants qui ont des petits rôles ou
des moins de tirs hollande et pierre
mondy
ils sont tous passés dans dans kaamelott
un paquet j'ai quelques noailles alain
chabat guy bedos
antoine de caunes au christian clavier
milliers de kent et à drucker grimbert
que voilà vous avez quasiment toutes les
stars c'est quoi ça c'est l'effet c'est
l'effet succès ou c'est votre quart des
adresses où c'est je pense que non non
non j'ai pas mon carnet de l'adresse mon
dieu aime et cc je crois qu'il ya un
truc très simple si qu'au delà de ce que
vous dites mon effectivement laissé de
sa essayer de bien travailler marches
attire attirant je crois qu'en fait ils
savent que ils savent que c'est écrit
par et pour les comédiens ça qui les
choses qu'ils sont magnifiques cent fois
mieux fait etc mais qui sont peut-être
plus de l'ordre de l'esthétique ou de
l'écriture là c'est moi j'organise quand
même une récréation pour comedia je ne
pense pas que je pense que ça s'est su
et je pense que je filme avant tout le
plaisir de jouer avant l'histoire que je
raconte j'ai c'est que tout soit bien
fait part en place que vous venez de
voir cette à cinecittà en italie c'est
en amont on essaye de mettre les moyens
vraiment dans le budget qui nous est
consacré mais vraiment ce que je peux
promettre aux acteurs qui viennent jouer
chez moi pas que dans kaamelott
d'ailleurs partout c'est que c'est écrit
sur mesure pour eux déjà y'a pas de
casting est aussi savent qu'ils vont
faire plaisir
je pense qu'il ya de grandes chances que
je pense que jarmon relativement réussi
mon coup je lis ce sont à plaindre
ils se battent pour venir en crise on
pas que ça doit se battre puisque gérard
dine venir
okada qui se battent et puis à qui j'ai
pas demandé c'est bas de s'en mêle ça
j'avais la curée bonne place c'est pas
des superstars mme ces légendes aux
familles comme le disait muc tout à
l'heure il ya votre père votre mère
votre belle-mère parce que notre papa
s'est remarié ou su marier un portois
l'apport vôtre
demi frère illias vos enfants aussi
qu'ils ont participé outre épouse
et costumière et pourquoi est ce que
vous faites participer votre famille et
pas de votre famille a tous beaucoup de
gens vous allez rencontrer
professionnellement à qui vous avez une
généralité
déjà je ne fais pas de casting donc
forcément je m'adresser aux gens que
j'ai vus jouer ailleurs
vous êtes quoi ils vont être capables il
avait commencé en plus de ça de ma
famille en plus des autres ils ont une
complicité évidemment avec le texte
puisqu'on a un peu la même
j'allais dire et j'ai hérité d'eux des
goûts les fibres voilà et donc du coup
quand ils reçoivent un texte de moi et
c'est vrai qu'il ya pratiquement pas de
dire avec son acteur on est tout de
suite dans le monte on s'amuse comme ça
et ça quelque chose de rassurant pour
vous aussi faites des trajets laurent
c'est une des meilleures façons qu'ont
et de se voir aussi je crois peut-être
une des façons les plus basses que c'est
un métier qui isole quand on est con
sabine ont exactement le tournage et moi
je suis avec eux à noël aussi je
présentais comme tout le monde mais
j'adore travailler avec eux je trouve
qu'en plus de ça on a une espèce de
vigilance qui s'installe presque
supérieur d'entre nous parce qu'on n'a
pas envie que qu'on vienne nous dire
qu'on est là parce qu'on est de la
famille non on veut faire plaisir et on
veut honorer la place que que nous nous
donnons mois chez mon demi-frère simon
qui a fait rire au corps que j'ai joué
chez lui j'ai la même attitude que lui
lâché moi c'est que ça très sérieusement
et que surtout ne vienne pas me
reprocher d'être là pour autre chose que
parce que je viens y faire il ya un côté
clan mais dans le bon sens du terme
voilà si c'est le sixième livre c'est le
dernier paru c'est le dernier diffusé et
c'est la fin de la série devait y en
avoir un de plus ouais on dit que
vous avez décidé de pas le faire pour
pouvoir accéder plus facilement au
cinéma puisque camelot doit être portée
au cinéma sous forme de trilogie c'est
vrai si je me lance un peu dans wii
c'est vrai que ça doit être une trilogie
si ça doit se terminer par 3,3 volet au
cinéma qu'en sait-il pas que s'applique
en plus j'ai décidé j'ai eu un petit
voilà j'ai des petits retards c'est que
je ne veux pas que mon premier film de
cinéma soit camelot voulait en faire un
autre il ya un projet ça s'appelait
monsieur carlson ça va devenir man
carlson parce que monsieur ça devait
être alain delon il paraît qu'ils vous
aillez pas d'autre mot plantaire de ce
moment le tournage ya donné son accord
ça se fait pas isabelle adjani a donné
son accord
oui on croise les doigts pour qu'elle si
oui enfin c'est pas du tout les mêmes
personnages tous la même idée voir et
comparer non mais c'est vrai que bon
ballon c'est compliqué ainsi c'est
compliqué mais voilà j'en ai un peu
souffert
finalement pas tant que ça parce que ça
m'a permis de rencontrer isabelle adjani
est donc le rôle et réécrit pour elle
puisqu'elle concerne monsieur ça devenir
une dame le dise l'histoire du coup on
est comme profondément modifier un
imaginaire à quoi mon thème est toujours
là ce que je voulais raconter y est mais
ça a quand même changé énormément
le tournage est prévu pour pour mars ils
ont donc d'un couteau on croise les
doigts pendant que j'écris le premier
film de camelot donc donc c'est pas l'un
que c'est
[Musique]